how you doing nice to meet you
riding
what's up guys we are live day 2 at the
South by Southwest Film Festival Alicia
I haven't seen you all day
you've been unfriending people it except
me I got a friend request yeah we're
finally friends on Facebook but my day
kicked off really early at the
unfriended party I got a tweet from the
dead girl which really freaks me out but
I also had a chance to shoot a video
where I discovered I'm a terrible
actress I had to put a fork into a
toaster and then pretend to be
electrocuted and then later on today I
went and talked to the evil geniuses
behind unfriended including Jason Blum
and they talked all about this new
inventive style for low-budget it's
almost like a new kind of found-footage
horror being shot on the computer
through Skype but what about you you
know what I did I met the guys from
Raiders which is a documentary about
these two dudes who back in the early
80s they recreated Raiders of the Lost
Ark shot by shot and it's his heartfelt
love letter to movies and making movies
and these guys were just so cool and we
had such a good time yeah and then I
went right from there to see this movie
called the boy disturbing right really
super unsettling about this kid slow
descent into madness it's kind of like
the origin story of a serial killer it
made me feel nauseous afterwards and I
have this like phobia of throwing up but
except when I see movies that make me
want to throw up because I feel like if
a movie makes me feel really crappy then
at least I could say you know what it
did its job well I'm looking forward to
hearing about ex machina I'm about to do
the red carpet and speak to Oscar Isaac
and domhnall gleeson and Alex Colin and
I spoke to Oscar earlier today I bumped
into him and he remembered me
he said I'm a me we had a good hug your
dog hug life forever
what are you up to tonight I'm gonna go
see ex machina I'm really excited about
that it's original size
I'm a real fan of Alex Carlin and I'm
hoping to get my mind expand it a little
bit make me think of some things and
then I
there's a little party tonight baby
little potty little party little action
I'm gonna say Lost River as well so we
will talk to you about that tomorrow on
our recap here from South by Southwest
but that nega movie clips I'm Alicia
moon I am Eric Davis keep coming back
come on
you